[Musik]
in der letzten folge arzt tommy von will
im einsatz für rega drei als coach
beobachtete die arbeit seiner berner
kollegen
nacht flug nach mallorca pilot philipp
sémon repatriiert mit der crew des
ambulanzjets einen muskel kranken
patienten
und schwierige rettung für pilot
ringmauer an der winterruhe der die
notärztin china noch mit einem
verunfallten kletterer aus der wand
nach einer zwischenlandung hebt romeo
tango mit der patienten an bord ab
richtung spital die rettung am
ritzlihorn atemregler team alles
abverlangt landung beim spital
interlaken der patientin betäubt von
schmerzmitteln wegen steinschlag ist er
20 meter in die tiefe gestürzt sein bein
ist zertrümmert
[Musik]
bitte spenden sie dann sind das
hochgebirge situation ist es ob sie das
wirklich so die abschüssige sie und dass
mein vater nicht unbedenklich hoch
gewählt
neben dem trümmerbruch hat leider keine
weiteren schweren verletzungen flugplatz
dübendorf hier ist jetpilot philipp
simmel als projektleiter im einsatz
er ist verantwortlich für die
beschaffung drei jahre neue ambulanzjets
430 millionen franken spezialisten
planen hier die medizinische
innenausstattung der jets im detail mit
dieser nachbildung des flugzeugrumpfes
man wolle sicherstellen dass mir eine
zukunft ohne probleme ohne risiko mit
dem leben der patientin das flugzeug mit
dass man nirgends ruhm hand zum drähte
zu den verschiedenen modifikationen
vorgespielt dass mit der winkel
abgeflacht haben dass man da rumpelt und
hand auch in der winkeler abflacht dass
man da an hormonen friedrichsruhe
befüllt sodass man das so optimal sind
nützen große herausforderung ist gewiss
mit dem flugzeug
das flugzeug ist grundsätzlich
schwächten sich um so mehr
die haben wir das flugzeug in flügen die
intensivstationen das heißt mir sehr
schwer medizinisches equipment in dem
flugzeug installiert und da ich sowieso
mit argusaugen des gewichts und lehre
dass man eben nicht schwer werden so
dass am schluss operationelle die
schranke geheftet der eingangsbereich
war wichtig im auswahlverfahren die rega
analysierte insgesamt 64 flugzeugtypen
aber auch die rampe wird verbessert
person und wo sie ihn sofort
[Applaus]
das schafft man jetzt nur allein die
luft
[Musik]
nach jahren der detaildiskussionen kommt
projektleiter 7 der realisierung seiner
jets schritt für schritt näher
das team von reger 10 ist nach der
rettung des kletterers zurück auf der
basis in wilderswil bei interlaken
[Musik]
fast 700 mal rückt reger 10 pro jahr aus
und immer wieder erleben pilot arzt und
rettungssanitäter extremsituationen
es fließe steam mission der luft habe
mich einfach erhalten
also muss es enormes vertrauen
zueinander und das schweißt zusammen
[Musik]
flughafen zürich
hier ist das herz der regel dass rega
center mit hangar und einsatzzentralen
notruf vom niesen
das ist okay jetzt sie sind aber
unverletzt das ist richtig haben sie ein
handy auf dem sie koordinaten ablesen
können hat das feld um sie herum und sie
waren auf dem wanderweg ich habe eine
idee wo sie sein könnten war es so ein
zickzack wanderweg den sie hinunter
gehen wollten
das war dann kein weg ich glaube ich
weiß wo sie sind hatte ich glaube ich
weiß wo sie sind haben sie im kohlwald
wird leiden sie auf alle fälle dort wo
sie jetzt sind weil da genau weil da
haben wir verbindung oder ganz sicher
genau dann gegen primäres evakuation ihr
sein dass man für natascha winter berge
gehe ich kann man sich schon in er es
auch noch besser steht für
fachspezialist helikopter
diese speziell ausgebildeten bergführer
der alpinen rettung schweiz unterstützen
die rega cruise bei schwierigen fällen
im gebirge
und ich demokratie noch nie wurde so
viel verkehr komplett jetzt noch besser
wäre es dem angestellten zunächst
erschöpft
die ziele von epic im foto rechts und
60.000 torino pohlig
will man auch nicht martin eingeholt
aber schon dass die kräftige klares und
verschiedene durch boden
aber nicht nur welche den dortigen werde
bergführer mario been
er hat heute blicke dienst als rsh hatte
cohen rettungs beobachten grüß gott der
helikopter wird in ca 5 minuten bei
ihnen seien wahrscheinlich wird er mit
einer winden aktion sie hinaus holen
dankeschön ein paar büros weiter wird in
einem ausschuss der geschäftsleitung die
zukunft der rega geplant es geht um die
neuen ambulanzjets die meisterin von mir
kommen haben wir intensiv verhandelt mit
der bombardier bezüglich eine integrale
wähler und system in dem flugzeug
projektleiter philipp sémon schlägt vor
die jets mit der zentrale zu vernetzen
dank des neuen wlan systems gegen
medizinische daten zum beispiel direkt
in die zürcher zentrale das anliegen ist
in diesem gremium mit ceo chef pilot und
chefarzt unbestritten die rega will
innovationen auch wenn es kostet locker
sieht demnach vor dass man sich immer
wieder neue ehre dass man sich immer
wieder hinterfragt und neue methoden
rettungsmethoden tut entwickeln neue
grad oder schafwolle schlacht ist eine
patientin liegt das in der schweiz oder
sechs im ausland kommt unter maradona
dem pioniergeist zu schaffen weiter und
darum heime aktuell projekt am laufen
voll von sage und schreibe 200 millionen
schweizer franken
neben den drei neuen ambulanzjets
beschafft die regler zur zeit auch drei
neue eli copter
helikopter romeo tango ist mit dem
gebirgsspezialisten der alpinen rettung
schweiz einer partnerorganisation der
rega zurück am niesen im abschüssigen
gelände wird er den erschöpften wanderer
auf die bergung vorbereiten
er sprach
unbedingt
kirchplatz stehen herr verbrauchen
durch die schlechten gesprächen darüber
nach
sowas
das leben doch
weiter unten wird der wanderer alleine
seinen heimweg antreten
er ist unverletzt der einsatz am niesen
ist einer von gleich drei präventiven
notrufen in diesen stunden von menschen
die nicht mehr weiterkommen aber
unversehrt sind
und der hand der halle mit dem handy
will der wirklich teilmaßnahmen corinna
nicht dass auch für die alpin rettet
dann wollen und wie im dritten fall
magath ahnt dass ich eine familie mit
kind und an kinder im spiel sind wird
auch immer sehr schwierig oder und dann
geht es hat wirklich mal sehen dass man
das macht bevor das marco hohner bevor
es passiert
die retter von riga 10 sind zurück auf
der basis
wie erleben sie einsätze für
freizeitsportler die sich leichtfertig
in gefahr bringen
die geschlachtet wie ein birdie
einfacher dann trainiert der 14 14 mal
und der comedian und das war spekuliert
dass kubica der funktionieren möchte
juni grundsätzlich meinen ärger den man
einfach zutritt zum helle und grundsatz
vom roten kreuz das man eigentlich jedem
muss jeder situation probieren
und der kann ja eigentlich noch am
prinzip und probieren nicht hinterfragen
warum muss sie warum ich die situation
hoch
seit 35 jahren ist die rettungsflugwacht
mitglied des schweizerischen roten
kreuzes philips siemens steckt
inzwischen wieder in seiner uniform
einen schönen abwicklung eine knappe
stunde wird die reise an die adria
dauern
aber der schrift intensivstation forst
beatmet worden
einen häcksler geraten
[Musik]
heute mit dem team arzt marcel von dach
beide kennen bis jetzt erst den
flughafen venedig nicht aber die stadt
[Musik]
hentschel
schon jetzt arbeite jetzt haben
[Musik]
und gut zum stopp von reststoffen
wie immer bleibt philipp sémon mit dem
co piloten bei seiner maschine zurück
cool ist
nein
einsatzleiterin geht die kuhn hat
feierabend
vor ihr liegt eine mehr als einstündige
heimfahrt ins glarnerland
schweigend saßen sie eine zeitlang
beisammen beanstanden
er ging zur tür als wollte er sich auf
den heimweg machen
doch dann geht's radio und die vergehen
höher werden kann ich das sehr schnell
ineinander geschichten und mit den ideen
anderer geschäft und foren haben das ist
bereit wären die verrechnete die
stammzellen als kann ihr zögern spürte
sagte er
heirate mich einfach ich liebe dich ich
werde mein lieber darauf verwenden dich
glücklich zu machen
die kunde ist ambulanzjets ist
inzwischen in venedig mit einem ambulanz
boot unterwegs
[Musik]
gesagt haben ja genau das richtige
ankunft beim spital
[Musik]
hast du dann auf sie
si
ja stimmen hamburg bonn ist eine miss ag
tätig
dr vom dach freut mich sie zu aber somit
schon von atemnot das hat sie nötig das
richtig gezählt würden sie zug und
schwyz luzern ist das gut
mit jeder frau zusammen ich sehe schwarz
wurde von der aok studie können sie mal
lud die junge sophie und stufen
auf druck sieht der foto logan
arzneimittel ihm drin
das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm das ist
völlig normal das ist noch gelungen
entzündung passieren der kaffee bekommt
controller hat sie kein lungenentzündung
das ist eine sehr gute nachricht ist das
wirklich so
das super dass im glarnerland
einsatzleiterin gt kuhn ist zu hause
angekommen
sie lebt im gleichen haus wie ihre
mutter zusammen mit zwei katzen nicht
weit von ihrem partner entfernt
eine große bedeutung für mich und ich
finde ich bin 20 jahre im zürichsee
wenn ich hier bin wir für mich mit der
zeit mit dem motto einander dafür steht
vielmehr für mich mit der sichel
geborgen gefühlt und so und will ich
schon immer in zurück schafften april
von ihrem wagen angeschafft wird ist für
mich immer so und so eine hol ich bin
ich weit weg vom schuss
[Musik]
der garten ist für erholung und
erinnerung
ich sage immer dass ich in der familie
die konflikte hier eine kleine
gedenkstätte für verstorbene
familienangehörige
in venedig sind rega crew und patient
bereit für die rückreise die tochter
verabschiedet sich sie war mit den
eltern in den ferien und wird später
einreisen
[Musik]
waren missbrauch aus infusionsständer
sondern mit dem kopf zur stelle wie ich
sehr gut sogar
ok
viele frühe marcello
der markt weiter zu lassen wir sind
jetzt gerade abfahren vom spital das
kultur mit dem hobby was man alles
machen darf
ich würde mich würde mal sagen so zum 15
tc stelle dass es automatisch
ich muss schlafen
der canal grande
sie mischten kanal ruhigen house tph vom
flughafen
das hat weniger welcher patient weiß
[Musik]
natürlich genial
für die letzte etappe geht es vom boot
wieder auf die straße
[Musik]
am flughafen wartet philip simon
allerdings lange vergebens auf das
ambulanzfahrzeug
die beliebte raus sind
wir nehmen
sehr gut wunderbar musik braucht
kmu sind
endlich treffen patient und crew ein das
ambulanzfahrzeug war auf umwegen
unterwegs die fahrt dauerte eine stunde
statt 15 minuten
herzlichst die kosten zur verfügung
ambulanzfahrer mich sowieso das gericht
die kultur ihnen flog auf dass immer
länger
jetzt war das handy in der hand kam mit
navi aber ich glaube ich so gut wie lieb
sie für eine gruppe 52 minuten
wir sind sofort los
die ehefrau des patienten steht noch
immer unter schock
[Musik]
hayden smart auto
in renchen ganze
ein buch
rund um die uhr unterwegs oft
kurzfristiger hinsetze kein tag wie der
andere
mittlerweile ein traumjob für philips
[Musik]
für die moskauer
sie ist ja auch noch mal dass google
hervor und sie stetig besser und haben
die linke sitzt darf als kompetenter
stelle dax notierte projektleiter das
ist der preis millionen projektleiter
mit der analytik in der tonart ihm
verbessern
es ist halb zwölf ankunft in zürich
[Musik]
rega basis wilderswil versackt und was
er darf und was hätte alles so ok also
ein zimmer und das ist nördlich von hat
westlich von nadja heimatlosen frau
irgendwo dazwischen wanderweg wovon grad
links aber ich war ja eher selten selber
sieht der kloß genannte sehr
wahrscheinlich
vorsprachen tommy und lauten empfang
hätte eigentlich sinnvoller liege dort
und ist jetzt aber im sand am strand
alarmiert aber es liegt die frau da
irgendwo im laden zwischen zwischen grad
und dann wieder ist also schwendgraben
arzt tommy von will lässt kontrollieren
ob das gestalt wichtig sitzt
gegenstand des gerichts zu
durch die gerichte durchschritten der
jammer dass die paketdienste und gegner
wirklich gemein
[Applaus]
arzt tommy von will macht sich zu fuß
auf die suche nach der verunfallten frau
zehn flugstunden entfernt material
hauptsitz des flugzeugherstellers
bombardier
[Applaus]
philipp sémon hat hier hunderte von
stunden verhandlungen geführt über
budget zeitplan und gewicht der neuen
ambulanzjets jede einzelheit wurde
festgelegt heute geht es um weitere
besprechungen wie etwa zum wlan system
[Musik]
und zum ersten mal kann philipp sémon
ein neues regal flugzeug besichtigen
[Musik]
ein großer tag
so ist es in diesen hallen werden jets
des typs challenger hergestellt hier
arbeiten insgesamt 2500 personen in 24
stunden schichtbetrieb die jets werden
von einer produktions stelle zur anderen
gerollt
jetzt müssen wir die brillen aufsetzen
auf dieser plattform sehen wir ihr
flugzeug
das muss es sein das ist es
offensichtlich fehle noch ein paar teile
aber das ist schon mal der anfang sein
2013 arbeite ich an diesem projekt und
jetzt das erste stück metall
[Musik]
ich bin der erste der den neuen riegert
berührt habe dass das flugzeug die wenig
gewöhnen sich das flug geht das heißt es
wird die verfolgung der unter im
dezember ist sehr lang und erzählt was
für netto jeder leistet augen oft
umstand dass desktop besonders flugzeugs
montiert ist und dann flügge wird und
damit luft
die rote flotte wird im jahr 2018 müsst
ihr durch das großereignis das heißt die
flüge auf herz und nieren überprüft
werden während sehr lang am boden das
heißt der kooperation wird ob landwirt
park ride für osi günther
aufrechterhalten und das ganze hört er
verständigte sich ferner dementsprechend
mehr zeit eine wand das umbau und die
neue flotte im 2018 in betrieb setzen
besuch muster cockpit
welches flugzeug fliegen sie heute 60 4
dann ändert recht viel
einige anfragen betraf das wetterradar
sie können es hier oder dort platzieren
oder auch auf dem primary fly display
es ist ein neues rad mit multi ski-ass
optimiert automatisch das suchmuster für
sie weniger bildschirm des iphones und
finden übersichtlich gestaltet viel
ergonomischer gestaltet und dran für
sensorik wenn man mit dem flugzeugtyp
bewerkstelligen
philipp sémon hofft dass er einen der
neuen jets in zwei jahren selber in die
schweiz überfliegen kann
zurück im napfgebiet hier hat arzt tommy
von will die patientin gefunden
doch die zahl in ruhe lassen welche
maschinen ich werde kommen wo es
aber wer jetzt glaubt mir nicht wenn ich
danach entspannen ja christlich
liberalen
start zur winden rettung
damit der körper
[Applaus]
vor allem mental viel wasser dass sie
das nicht viele nächte reef liegt
praktisch das jahr vorbereitung sind
diese nicht gefahr dass das echt
fliegenden welt ist
[Musik]
gut
hallo
[Musik]
ja das muss man sich ja nicht
roboter zu bauen
[Applaus]
häufig kommen
[Musik]
doch recht schwer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das wollen wir noch mehr
nächste woche treffen
[Musik]
die patientin hat das bein mehrfach
gebrochen der heilungsprozess wird
monate dauern
rettung um rettung unfälle krankheiten
schicksale
diese erlebnisse hallen im privatleben
der rega crew nach danke dass ich da so
ein fakt dass man sich bewusst wird und
vielleicht lange somit problem so
einstimmt der wahre problem besser kennt
[Musik]